it's because of you Robert that my
children were told they can't sit at the
lunch table cuz your daddy rates little
girls you can deny all you want to and
for that you can go to hell are Kelly's
ex-wife Andrea did not hold back about
how the singers alleged actions affected
her family in surviving our Kelly and
now his estranged daughter buku Abby
breaks her silence on allegations
surrounding the six-part lifetime
docu-series our Kelly has denied all
claims against him presented in the
docu-series on Thursday the singer's
daughter whose real name is Joanne Kelly
took to Instagram with a lengthy post
writing I do apologize if my silence to
all that is happening comes off as
careless that is my last intention I
pray for all the families and women who
have been affected by my father's
actions trust I have been deeply
affected by all of this she added
reminders of how terrible my father is
and how he should be speaking up against
him rude comments about my family
fabricating me my siblings and her
mother's part etc does not help my
family me my sister my brother and my
mother in our healing process the same
monster you all confronting me about is
my father I am well aware of who and
what he is I grew up in that house so
buku said it took her three days to
write her statement and explained why
she chose to keep quiet for so long she
said it was for her peace of mind her
emotional state and healing and we
understand that and aleeah's boyfriend
at the time of her death in 2001 Damon -
also opened up about our Kelly and his
disturbing relationship with a singer
when she was just a teenager here's what
he had to say in an interview with
Kenyatta the hip-hop motivator I
remember Leah trying to talk about it
and she couldn't you know she just would
leave it at that dude was a bad man and
I didn't really want to know what he did
she said that I might feel the need you
know some French to just deal with it
just just cuz that's what a man does but
it just was so much hurt for her to
revisit it it was like I wouldn't even
want to revisit it without a
professional was terrible - who was also
the co-founder of Rockefeller Records
also admitted that a Liege trauma was
why he wouldn't have anything to do with
jay-z's records with our Kelly I was
like bro you know I homie violated he
violated my girl so you know when he
moved forward with that I was like yo I
wanna party that put my part of that -
uh - Ali as breast cancer thing he also
implied that J's decision to work with
Kelly was a key factor in the pair
ending their professional relationship
I knew morally we want the same girl so
to me Rockefeller was over now since the
docu-series Ayers stars continue to
speak out and take a stance against our
Kelly one of those people is Lady Gaga
who released a lengthy statement on
Twitter Wednesday night that read in
part quote I stand behind these women
1,000% believe them know they are
suffering and in pain
Gaga also called the allegations against
our Kelly horrifying and indefensible
the pair collaborated in 2013 on the
song do what you want the second single
of Gaga's album artpop Gaga had the song
removed from iTunes and streaming
platforms and she vowed to never work
with our Kelly again and I love that I
mean I think a lot of people are taking
a stance right now and Mathew Knowles is
someone who spoke out he says the
Destiny's Child never left he and Tina's
sight when they worked with our Kelly
and eventually they rejected the collab
that they did with him because it didn't
feel like a good song Cara Delevingne
lost fifty thousand Instagram followers
after she slammed our Kelly she posted
this pic with her reaction captioned the
followers I lose clearly don't agree
with what I have to say
people that support the ideas and
actions of others who are moving
backwards and not forwards in 2019 I
want to be more confrontational I think
that was a really funny post for her to
share especially with a more heavy issue
that we're talking about but authorities
reportedly are looking into allegations
against the singer and we're gonna keep
you guys up to date on this for the
latest be sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time I'm at Halle
underscore Stephen and I met Courtney
underscore teza know bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]